Gentlemen gentlemen, here's my nine. My, my arguably,
arguably the strongest name we've had today.
You want to go from top left to bottom? Uh, Hunter Hunter, golden time.
Uh [inaudible] uh, ping-pong animation Sakamoto,
Kai mob cycle 100, but on a fish and Jojo.
I'll tell you what this is. This is the guys I have good tastes.
Good guys. Guys. You want to know a personality?
I have absolutely no personality.
Sorry that I don't like incest gone. Is that what you want to see on my list?
The lack of him says, this is the, this is the,
I cite my sources in my video essay, like levels of like taste.
You know what I mean?
If I had to use a name like the top nine shows that I have,
and like a little bit of variation genre, this'll be it.
No, because I look at this list and I'm just like, yeah, this is, this is what,
this is what my nine by nine would be.
If I literally went through my like modern Mao and just pick the top highest
rated animate on that map. I'm trying,
I'm trying to take my tastes and enemy God. And this is my taste. I dunno, man.
Like he did it to normal. This is no, no, no. It's not even normally.
It's just it's try-hard.
Legit. This is legit. My, my favorite nine shows. Well, I mean,
obviously we don't have to talk about hunt on tickets.
We've talked about golden time. Golden time is like my favorite Volcker on her.
Yeah. Ping pong.
Can you kick him? Can you talk about ping-pong.
A hundred percent, right? I love ping pong. Ping pong. Right?
Other than like mob. Okay.
That's also why I love them all for the similar reasons.
Like ping-pong is like one of the only enemies, right?
You got all these stupid animals where the guys ops. it. No one gives a.
Right? Like, okay. Wow. Kyoto is a giant Dick again. Right? Cool.
We have another use of guy. Oh, they're overpowered or, Oh,
they have an ability that unique to them. You know what? Real life sucks, man.
No one has a unique ability and I've really liked.
There was a anime that was like, bro, life kind of sucks, man.
Sometimes people just got to be better at things that you love,
even if they hate it. That's what, but that was so real. And it hurt, man.
It hurt because I've been on both sides of the ping pong, like animation,
like the characters. I've been talented at something that I hated.
And I felt bad for people who really wanted to be good at that thing that I was
good at.
And I've also tried my hottest at something and you speak Japanese fluently. So,
you know, I've been on both sides of the spectrum of things on the animation.
So I'm kidding. No, but.
Really ping, ping pong, ping pong. What I call on what I call ping pong.
It's a lifespan.
Yeah. It, it, it hurt because I was like,
you really had to like pull that out of me. Like that,
that made me a little like, God. Okay. Yeah. Then I'm curious.
Have you seen a March comes in like a line?
No. Okay.
Cause I think if you loved ping-pong you would love that because mom's comes in
like a lion is the complete opposite Muslims in like a line is about a genius
who can't understand the idea of losing. Yeah. Right.
But that in itself is what's causing him to lose in real life. Yeah.
So it's literally the opposite of paintball,
but that's the same school when they're like you're a gifted.
Child, then they can't do anything later on it.
Right. Exactly. I mean, and obviously like, uh, I don't wait.
[Inaudible] that's so funny, man.
My boy is hilarious. Second Modo is one of the funniest.
Sacramento is so good. It's so fun. It's so funny. You can put that.
It's like the Mr. Bean of Adams.
It's like the misdemeanor of animated,
Mr. Bean was like a like handsome millionaire who was playing.
So you really get to a me when you just like were like, yeah. Pedophilia.
Here's what I don't understand though. Every three by three, right.
As we've established so far in every three by three I've seen back when it was
big,
has at least one show that like universally.
Right? That is just a. I think all of these shows are fantastic, which is why.
I just press X to doubt. I just don't like shows Jerry,
would you think it would have put like my whole mouth demon of some in this?
They still listing was mad as.
I dunno. Like you don't have like a, do you have a guilty pleasure enemy?
Honestly. No, not really. I don't, I don't really watch anime ever.
The grand reveal. I frankly I've revealed this before. I don't, I never want,
I never want to rewatch anime. Right. So you wouldn't really watch any of these.
No. Why would I be watching a 40 watch?
Because it's great because you don't want to re-experience it. Yeah.
Not really. I'll be honest with you. I'd rather experience that.
So there's no show. You will never have you never gotten to the point right?
Where you're just, you just,
you're just tired of trying something new and because no, no, no, no. You're,
you're tired of trying something new.
Why do we need the sensor sad? I'm just tired of trying. I'm going to go back.
What does this? Because,
because sometimes you try something to you and you you're just like, man,
this just ain't doing it for me. You just want something,
you want something that it's comfortable.
Yeah. It's yeah. I don't know. For me that feels sad.
It feels like you're trying to capture something that's gone in your life.
You know what I mean? I don't know.
I feel sad time in this photo and I don't like it, but you're like, I dunno,
like you're chasing something that doesn't exist anymore in my mind.
Of me because in my mind, right. I got go. I could, I could easily watch.
Yes. Would I willingly do it of my own free will?
No, no. Because like I E to, to bring it the other way,
like for me watching new shows is me chasing that high. That,
that is me chasing that high that I felt with the shows I've already liked,
but the more anime you watch and just the older you get,
that just gets harder and harder.
Don't watch my channel anymore. And that's it.
Like reveal of this video? God doesn't work.
No, I do. I watch anime and I should try it.
I mean, look, honestly, like I feeling SaaS about this three by three,
just because again,
because all nine of these shows are like universally praised. All right.
It's golden time university praise. I like more was trash.
I love golden golden time. It was golden time.
Took everything towards trash and I liked it,
but it was trout golden time took everything Tara Dora did and just perfected
it. Yeah.
I would literally it's like, if you, like, in my mind,
it's like my two favorite, like Roman.
Yeah. Golden time.
But golden time felt like the better on golden time is my favorite romance of
all time. I would think. Yeah. Golden time.
[inaudible] I've met less people who say they didn't like golden time. Yeah.
Cause like the thing about golden time is that, you know, there are,
there were floors because to the liked Banbury as a character, let's be honest.
Like I just like talk, talking about compressing your memory.
Like I I've only just remembered that ghost boundary was the thing.
And now it's just something I've just liked.
That was like a black spot in this like amazing series.
That's I seem to remember golden time, but like, I think that's a golden time.
I just think this is, this is how adult romance should be. This is,
this took everything that was good.
As you said about Torah Dora and just made it better, perfected it,
put it in university.
Didn't make it like just this high school romance had enough adult elements that
didn't have an annoying lowly yonder. She was really,
I love kg. The, again, the gambler that was amazing. She's great.
Well, my favorite shows and it's sad that no one gives a chance,
but it also weird that it's only in seven 20 P that's pretty weird.
No 40 P I think or something. It was never released.
[Inaudible].
And it's such a shame because it's such a good show,
but it was either that or like one ounce. I really love.
What else is fun you, but I mean, I don't know.
Yes. I mean, I guess it looks very basic from the.
No, it's not basic. It's amazing.
It's not basic in the sense where we were putting on nine favorite shows.
But what we're saying is that like there isn't a single guilty pleasure enemy
here because obviously.
Guilty pleasure enemy while I could show her those bad or emo that's more than
okay.
That's criminal, in my opinion,
a guilty pleasure is a show that you love no matter what, even though you know.
It is. Yep. Okay. But then when I was making this nine by nine,
like say dead man Wonderland, I love to have my Wonderland,
but I never finished. And it was, you know, it was kind of because of it,
but like, I don't think it's better than any of these shows.
Cause like I've, I've talked to you and I know what your tastes are basically.
And I don't see a call me out.
I don't really see that representative because I know like my tastes like,
you know me gone, what do you mean? I mean, like you,
you hung out for a couple of years. I'm only like one of your face.
We only see each other every day.
Like I know you love like hardcore brutal shows like Joe,
Joe backy Gantz. I'm surprised. I thought back he was going to,
I fell back. He was going to be up there as well.
I mean, I love Becky as like this,
cause there's a few episodes in and it's like Mitch,
but that was so many funny moments that like it'll stand on me forever. Right.
Here's the best way I can put this.
I know you like Chad shows that that's the best way.
That's the best way I can just watch him on his tastes. Like, like it's,
it's like, it's just got Chad characters in it. You know what I mean?
Tried characters.
That's why I really want Connor to watch or read faster Norstar. No,
you would love that. I like the right amount of chat. It's just too much chat.
Sometimes a little too much. You know? What do you mean? You might Jojo.
That's a different, that's a different kind of chat.
That's like Jody was like the built different anime, like that's its own league.
So as I had said, like I think Judah should even be treated as animate.
It's a lifestyle.
Yeah. It's an artwork. But like, I dunno.
Especially the North star. When I see that,
I don't really find it appealing because that like,
they're just like to match show. I want a bit of weakness to the character.
Right? I mean.
If you've read it you'll know, every character is weak.
As. Really. Okay. Okay. Fine. Fine. Fine.
I think you should read it. You'll love it. Yeah. Yeah.
It me off when I'm watching an anime and the man.
Character is like a wimp beyond comprehension and just cause us any problems
himself because he's a wimp and I'm like, listen,
all you gotta do is just say no.
And you wouldn't have been dragged off to a cult or something about DECA.
I don't know. There's something else.
There's a lot of shows where I'm just like,
this literally could have been avoided if you just like slept yourself two
seconds. Like this whole problem.
No, I'm not satisfied. I'm not satisfied.
Just some. You know what I mean? Like you're expecting me to have to,
this is like, this is like too polished. I have good tastes. What can I say?
I can, I can make a better nine, a three by three by three by three.
For me it would be like, like I said, I'll see if it's fair to be Joe, Joe,
Bucky, Becky. But like, I.
Love Becky, but it's not in my top nine shows.
But you talk about it so often. Yeah. But like.
I love it, but it's,
I wouldn't put it higher than any of these for enjoyment in my mind.
But like it's it's okay. Because.
I love and show that I want to talk about, I like different, I guess.
But it's okay. Like this is, this is like getting here.
I guess this, we should have defined the rules more appropriately.
Should be like kind of give me the nine shows that you think about keep you up
at night.
Yeah. That's what I did. I did.
They used to put your nine favorite shows that represent you. What? Like,
what I don't understand is you say that like the shows I talk about and the
shows I like are not the same. Why would you talk about a show?
If it's not your favorite?
Right? It's like, well, ping pong. Right? Right.
It's all of it is encapsulating the show. There's nothing more to add.
I'm like just watch it. Like it's amazing. I love it.
I can't, I can't improve. Nobody's talking about that.
That that's that's the exact point. Right? Because you,
sometimes you see a good show and you're like, me. That was a good shot.
Like I like love to talk about it. Yeah. Yeah.
But sometimes you watch a show and you're like, man, this is,
this is sticking with me. You know what I mean? This is I I'm punk rock with me.
Huh? I'm not saying people shouldn't be on this, but like what,
what shouldn't be on this Hunter, Hunter, dude, Hunter, Hunter, bro. That.
That move me, man.
I see you talking more about Bucky than Hunter Hunter. Yeah, let's do because.
Okay. Let's be.
Psycho and Hunter. And so I rarely hear you talking about it.
I talk about one punchline,
more than talk about mob psycho one punch because I think motorcycles a better
show than one punch, man. Well then why wouldn't you talk about mob psycho,
if it's a better shot? Well, again,
because it's about a show and I feel like there's not much to say it's amazing.
Like just go watch it. Like, but this is like my favorite show.
I love Becky right? Where I have to sit there and be like, listen,
get to the part where he someone and becomes extra powerful.
Like I love having that conversation again. If you haven't seen Becky,
there was a scene where he has sex, honestly.
And that one scene is enough to be like animated of the year of my mind.
I like give it. That's exactly what I'm to about.
That's exactly.
That's a scene that stuck with you and you can bring up and you.
Why was that? Not the way that I see it is that like,
let's say God wants to take me to like an event. And he's like,
he has to specifically tell me like kind of don't bring up the back of the sex
scene to like my friends. That's the level of like,
I just want to talk about it like that.
It's not like it's defined by taste for some reason.
I just want to talk about that scene and how weird is.
Because like I like kind of, kind of talking to you.
I know what sh what kind of shows you would like, you know, you,
you look at someone's mood three over three,
and you can like recommend some shows that they would like, for example,
like I knew for example, that you would love a show.
Like [inaudible], you know what I mean? Cause that
, that, that is Ramy. It's grimy. It's a Chad anime
. You know what I mean? It's just corner. It just, you know, I'm just going to
say, if I didn't see this three by three and you told me.
Breaking all the fish is like, and if you ask me, recommend me an anime.
The last one I would bring up for me, for you. Why it again,
it just doesn't seem like a show. You would like.
What? I love that that's actually like.
I can say the biggest,
the biggest one for me is like mob psycho and Hunter. Hunter.
It's my favorite show and the volt. Sorry. Honda.
Honda is my favorite show of all time. What about Jojo?
I don't really count that as a Sheridan,
but it is a show because it has to be categorized,
but there's no dessert Jojo category,
but they should be as far as I'm concerned, you know, what,
what is this Jojo category then? I just, Joe Joe is like its own beast. Right?
Like I can't, I there's nothing. You can compare Jojo.
No, I, I agree with him. I disagree.
Pedro to do something right now to it. No.
It's it's it's not, it's not exactly the same. It's not exactly this.
I'm not saying they're both the same thing,
but they give off the same kind of feeling. You know what I mean?
Where it's just like,
there are some ridiculous things happening and you're just having a good time.
I'm not saying that they're on like the same level or anything,
but they give off the same vibe is what I'm talking about. But they're both,
I've always said that just both insane. But the thing is,
is that a bunch of eighties and nineties in back then had this
kind of feel to it? Yeah. Like FIS,
the North star also has scenes where it's just like, what the did I just read?
And you just recommended them that to him because he said, no, that's it.
That's exactly what I'm was. You were like halfway through was like, right.
Let's just be gay now. Like that. That's that's like, I love that. Trust me.
There's a lot of gay parts and I just thought it was like the manliest manly
anime of in existence. Like I guess that's pretty gay. Yeah.
That is pretty good.
There's a thing called Bharat. I don't know.
I was going to say the why the, why I'm saying music videos pretty manly,
but I pinata fish is one of my favorite shows as well. love it. This is great.
But, but,
but I was expecting that because you've talked about it for muffin on a fish.
Right. You've even made a whole video on pornography. So I expected that. But.
So you're complaining that I picked good shows is that.
Yes, because everybody's three by three has to have at least one show where it's
like.
Let's see if I could put a bad show that I like in my three.
There's got to be a least one. You'll see the money. There's gotta be a,
what I'm saying is every three by three houses have at least one showed that you
know is. You just don't look, look honestly,
what is it that the world got in the nodes? That's a show.
Would you put that on yet?
Yeah, probably would let you see what I'm making this. Right. We had like what,
like an hour to make this I'm thinking like, boom,
I'm putting my favorites on that. The classics. Okay.
He's a bit of, I can word it.
I understood more about you as a person from your hint. I tastes than I do.
But that's,
I feel like anyone could get my hand tight tastes to figure out kind of
recommends mother knows breasts.
I look at this and I'm like,
this could be anyone's three minutes or this was a,
this was a randomly generated image.
I said this was made by an AI learning program from like the randomly generated
sample from people's top light.
I put in the AI inoffensive.
Yeah. There's a lot of them and like in good faith, I couldn't put on there.
Cause I'm like, I honestly don't remember that much from the show. So like,
I don't know what to put on there. Like these are the nine shows, right?
If you like name, name nine shows that you love right away.
These are the first night.
Okay. I'll be honest with you. Honestly. I may, maybe it does make sense.
Cause REM you think REM is your wife.
That's just like zero. That tells me zero about you as this by three.
This is the most vanilla vanilla.
I'm sorry. There's no gang bang or Opry or grape incest in here. Okay.
What I'm what I'm trying to say is I like good shows too.
I'm sorry that you like Harry Susan, me or even galleon and a black lagoon.
The most to thousands of animating existence.
The fact is that that shows the fact is the fact is that you got something about
all my tastes. You can get it about this. I like good.
Why is that hard to understand? I look at this.
This could be any one of our fans. Well,
this could be our fans have any one of our fans who was like trying to impress
us, being like, yes, my favorite YouTube. But I also have good animators.
I have.
Good taste. When you going to do about it, have taste, jokes that you.
Want for it. Yeah. I was expecting I'm built different anyone to have a taste.
It was you. No, no, no.